for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so we've mentioned nuclear reactions
before but we haven't really talked much
about them we mentioned that they were
kind of the exception to the law of mass
conservation so what are they simply
they are reactions of atomic nuclei so
nuclei is plural for nucleus so atomic
nucleus there are reactions that occur
in the atomic nucleus so this excludes
the orbital electrons or the outside
electrons we haven't yet talked about
orbitals but if you know what those are
cool if not no worries not important
right now so let's kind of compare
chemical reactions to nuclear reactions
with chemical reactions electrons react
the outside electrons the over electrons
all right these are outside of the
nucleus nuclear reactions nucleons react
right the nucleons and the nucleon
specifically are the protons and the
neutrons protons and neutrons inside the
nucleus that's why they're called
nucleons so now in chemical reactions
atoms of an element do not change into
atoms of a different element during the
course for reaction so if we start off
with sodium atoms on the left side of
the reaction reactants and then we get
products those sodium atoms might be
part of a different chemical compound
than what they started with but their
identity as sodium atoms does not change
okay in nuclear reactions however atoms
of an element do change into atoms have
a different element during the course of
reactions and that's that's a really
important difference and that
specifically because we're talking about
the nucleus and in the nucleus there are
there are protons and neutrons right and
protons the number of protons defines
the identity of Anna of an atom of an a
certain element so it
if the number of protons changes we've
got a different element right okay so
that's really really important whereas
in chemical reactions things can gain
and lose electrons but not change their
identity okay next thing is that
chemical reactions have relatively small
energy changes on the order of 10 to the
third kilojoules now that's not a small
amount of energy necessarily not all of
them are have that much energy they
could have less but the point is that
relative to nuclear reactions chemical
reactions have small energy changes
because nuclear reactions have really
really large energy changes on the order
of 10 to the 8th kilojoules so that's a
hundred thousand times more right the
nuclear reaction as far as energy than
chemical reactions so again this says
this 10 to the third kilojoules is not
small amount so that I mean it for
example like if you have an explosion in
a laboratory that could be due to a
chemical reaction right and it might be
contained within that room or even that
lab bench for instance right but a
nuclear reaction some of them can they
can I mean we're talking about things
like for instance atomic bombs when they
explode they release tons and tons and
tons of energy right the difference
between the energy associated with
nuclear reactions of chemical reactions
it's quite vast okay so and of course
those aren't the only two examples of
chemical reactions that nuclear
reactions just just an example that sort
of lends to the difference between these
two now in chemical reactions there's no
changes in masses to detectable mass
changes so the mass of the reactants m
is just going to be mass the mass of the
reactants will equal the mass of the
products okay whereas whereas in nuclear
reactions or as in nuclear reactions
there are changes in mass that are
detectable the match the reactants does
not equal the mass of the products okay
so the mass can actually be converted
into energy which is kind of crazy we
won't really talk too much about that
right now or in this series how
we may talk about it more when we talk
about nuclear chemistry in detail so now
isotopes react the same when it comes to
chemical reactions and that's because
the number of electrons determines
what's happening I still just have
different number of neutrons not
necessarily different number of
electrons right so neutrons have nothing
to do with the electron chemistry right
the electron reacting but in nuclear
reactions isotopes react differently the
reason why is because isotopes have
different numbers of neutrons and
neutrons are nucleon to the nuclear
reaction so if something has different
number of neutrons the nucleus of that
atom is different and so we can expect a
different reaction now when it comes to
nuclear reactions nuclei react because
they are unstable and unstable nuclei
are said to be radioactive meaning that
they spontaneously decay into some other
nucleus okay so we're going to write the
reactions like this where X is of course
the atomic symbol X is the atomic symbol
sort of go out this way the atomic
symbol which tells us which element
elements nucleus we're talking about
total a is the mass number so let's show
that a different color is that purple
the total a is the mass number which of
course is the number of nucleons right
it's the number of protons plus the
number of neutrons in that nucleus and
the total Z that's the atomic number
right the number of protons so what
we're going to do when we talk about
these reactions we're going to think
about balancing them balance these
nuclear reactions right so when
balancing them what we really want to
pay attention to is we want the total a
on the left side to equal the total a on
the right side same thing with the total
Z on the left side and the total see on
the right side we want them to be equal
right now I wrote here the atomic symbol
for this one is X and over here is why
that's just indicating that the identity
can change right the starting nucleus
that we the thing that we start with its
unstable that's going to be called the
parent okay what we start with and then
whatever it gets turned into right the
resulting stable nucleus is called the
daughter okay so there are a few
different types of radioactive decay
that will be talking about and they are
listed here alpha decay beta or beta
minus decay specifically positron
emission or paid a plus emission
electron capture and gamma emission so
these are the Greek letters here Greek
letter alpha Greek letter beta a Greek
letter gamma down here now one thing I
do want to mention is that often times
these three here are sort of grouped
together as beta decay as beta to get
decay and I'm not really a fan of
grouping them that way although I do
mention it obviously I make I have
separate videos on each of these in and
the reason why is because each of them
is kind of the wrong thing and what I do
want to mention though is that that they
are classified together often all
together as beta decay but if a problem
where a textbook ever just mentions beta
decay without explicitly telling you
which one of these three it's talking
about it's talking about beta minus
decay mention that more later so if we
had a radiation source here launching a
beam of radiation at a detector screen
and on either side of the
name we had a positively charged and
negatively charged metal metal electrode
what we'd see is at the beta minus
particle negatively charged would tend
towards the positively charged plate the
alpha particle being positively charged
would tend towards the negative plate
the negative charge plate and V gamma
particle being having no charge we go
just go straight through unaffected okay
and an alpha particle having two protons
and two neutrons no negative charge has
a plus two charge so makes sense that it
would tend towards negative charge the
beta hat being natively charged gonna
tend towards positive charge gamma no
charge not going to tend to work either
those and if we're I'm not mentioning
positron electrons but you could
probably guess where they would go right
I'll leave that to you to think about
anyway I hope that video was helpful in
introducing these thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying